the Super Nintendo is my first console
it shaped the way I think and feel about
videogames today from its deep RPGs to
lengthy action adventures so needless to
say that revisiting this platform in its
games sent me on field trips which sets
the SNES classic apart from the NES
classic is inherent what the platform
offered in its era took me from 8-bit to
16-bit open the door for games would be
much more expansive and nuanced this is
what propels the SNES Classic from
simply being a novelty first let's look
at what you get the console itself two
controllers a five-foot HDMI cable a
five-foot USB mini cable to power the
system a USB power brick and a little
treat an old-school folded poster not to
mention the 21 games pre-loaded onto the
system all for 80 bucks the SNES classic
looks identical to the original that
released in North America but much
smaller and lighter the power button
function is just the same and the reset
switch brings you back to the main menu
it's actually the only way to get back
to the home screen and it's kind of
annoying if your setup isn't within
reach eject and the cartridge slot are
just for show since aren't any
cartridges to insert the front panel may
look like the original controller ports
but it pops outward and stays attached
the controllers themselves are identical
to the original SNES and the buttons
have the same solid tactile feel a
downside is that the d-pad feels a bit
stiff compared to modern game pads one
thing you don't have to worry about this
time around is coeur d'alene at about 5
feet it's twice as long as the NES
classic controllers at the back of the
console you'll find the meaning USB port
for power and HDMI out this little thing
doesn't need much power with its 5 volts
spec and can even be powered through a
USB port built into TVs or a computer
saving you an outlet the SNES classic
upscales games from their 240p
resolution to 720p a multiple of the
original resolution native 1080p would
have resulted in slight pixel Distortion
now let's fire this thing up the system
boots straight into the snappy main menu
options are up top where you can
customize the visuals want fake scan
lines from the days of CRTs traditional
four by three or perfectly square pixels
it's up to you and here you can choose
the type of border you want to fill
your widescreen display since all games
run as they did back in the day if you
turn on my gameplay demo which uses your
own gameplay footage or classic den
while using Filton footage Mario will
walk by and hit a game block from the
main menu if you leave your system idle
for a minute it'll start to roll
gameplay footage in the background it's
cute just like the lovely menu music the
suspended point system returns from the
NES classic you could stop and resume a
game at any point the tricky part is
games with internal saves can have the
data point overwritten if you enter an
earlier suspend point now the reason why
you'd want an SNES classic is to revisit
the greatest hits from Nintendo 16-bit
libraries or experience what you might
have missed all in one packaged not to
disparage the 8-bit era but what
separates the SNES from the NES is that
the extra power afforded developers the
opportunity to create greater games more
expressive visuals for stronger
characterizations and game worlds deeper
stories longer adventures and more
nuanced mechanics and some of the best
soundtracks in all of gaming
I genuinely enjoyed pouring hours into
Super Mario RPG again from it's
unforgettable songs to unprecedented
story beats in the Mario universe it's
truly unique and what other game will
you have Bowser peach and Mario fighting
alongside each other it was an
achievement in world building and
ushering in a new wave of RPG fans Final
Fantasy 3 or better known as Final
Fantasy 6 opened a massive world to us
with 40 plus hours of role-playing
giving you every reason to gather party
members learned their roles and
abilities and take down kefka and his
evil empire movements a bit slow and
random encounters are dated but
unraveling Terra's story and all of its
branches still has a place in 2017
another tremendous RPG and Secret of
Mana deserves a full playthrough I want
to get a hundred percent in Super
Metroid a sterling example of the
metroidvania genre we still see today we
even get a real release of Star Fox 2
and while it's a game that hasn't aged
well it's neat that the SNES classic
offers something exclusive I haven't
even mentioned Super Mario World Legend
of Zelda linked to the past or
earthbound many of these games are
realizations of ideas set in motion from
the NES era and transcend their Hardware
limitations of their time speaking of
hardware that emulation delivers an
authentic SNES experience I spent time
with all 21 titles to get a feel for how
they ran by and large the games look
true to form and run exactly as you
would expect for better and worse which
also means a few games suffer from
framerate drops Street Fighter 2 turbo
had some slowdown with characters
pulling off flashy attacks Megaman X did
as well so the system is mimicking the
performance of the real Hardware
adhering frame rates of the original
cycles of these games it's not game
breaking but it is noticeable and
undermined a few moments the SNES
classic is a closed system what you see
is what you get
barring a hypothetical firmware update
or expansion and wouldn't have been nice
to see Chrono Trigger or Final Fantasy 2
or Final Fantasy for sure but that
doesn't negate the fact that we still
have an all-star roster yes I'm aware
that there are so many ways to play
these games and we've had several
versions of them through the years but
to have this lineup of iconic games in
one place in an easy accessible and
convenient fashion makes the SNES
classic worth seeking out if Nintendo is
looking to capitalize on
16-bit nostalgia I'd say they did a damn
fine job
[Music]